[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rick stroud joining us on loan from the
tampa bay times and uh
i think still in new orleans getting
ready to fly back to tampa uh rick
thanks for joining us what is it about
the saints that gives the tampa bay
buccaneers trouble
you know dan i i just think that sean
payton does such a terrific job i mean
you look at the record that he has
without a quarterback named drew brees i
think it's like 13 and three and
you know they're so well prepared um
that's a physical physical defense that
puts a lot of pressure on tom brady
everybody tries to write they're
successful in doing it and you know
seven of brady's
17 interceptions since he's been a tampa
bay buccaneer have come against the
saints he hasn't beaten them in the
regular season so
clearly you credit the coaching and and
their players
i also thought about that quote where he
was sort of off the cuff having fun with
the manning brothers where he's talking
about defenses it's like cars or dogs
chasing cars and i thought golly that's
the kind of thing that comes back to
haunt you do you think the same thing
i did i thought this is not the week to
be talking about dogs chasing cars
because you know you're the car and uh
they caught them so
uh you know it just wasn't a good idea
but you know tom tom is is feeling
himself in tampa as we know he's found
his voice
um and in doing that you know look it
felt like there was a lot of hubris with
the bucks yesterday you know i i just
felt that
um they did beat him in the divisional
playoff that was the one that mattered
obviously brees was you know a shell of
himself and all of that um but but this
is the team that's won the nfc south
four years in a row and and now has a
you know sort of a a leg up on the head
to head so
you know if all the years in the nfc if
you're going to go to the playoffs you
need to win your division because
there's too many good teams you know
with one one loss
and so you know they did it last year
the hard way but there were no fans or
very few fans
on the road that won't be the case so
it's going to be a battle i think all
the way to the end with these two teams
how would you assess tampa's defense
well i mean you know
again
they're playing you know with a with a
short deck i mean they're missing their
corners they hope to get guys like
carlton davis sean murphy bunting back
after the buy this is a much needed rest
for them
um you know richard sherman was active
was there just to finish a game if they
needed him so
that certainly helped them hurt them on
the back end yesterday you saw that but
i think they made mistakes uh just of
emotion you know devin white can't get
you know a horse collar penalty
unfortunately hurt jameis winston on
that then gets another roughing the
passer um you know and then ends up with
a taunting penalty
you know this team this team hurts
itself there was one play
you know where they have an interception
in the end zone
with antoine winfield jr
he's eating w's in the end zone while
the flags dropping on will golston for
roughing the passer i mean that's just a
bad look for a young team that that
needs to know
uh you know sort of how to act and
i i just felt like they didn't handle
their emotions very well yesterday and
they got to get better at that because
they've talked about penalties all year
they cut them out after the chicago game
a year ago but they're still happening
so
you know they can't beat themselves
they're a better football team than
saints they didn't show it yesterday
most threatening team in the nfc to
tampa bay is who
um
well if you can't win the division
that's going to be tough but i would say
i would say the best team i've seen and
they got to get healthy is the dallas
cowboys
you know the rams certainly have the
formula because they have some some top
flight defensive player with jalen
ramsey and aaron donald in that
but i think you can beat them i
i look at the cowboys if they get their
defense together and those guys are
healthy offensively with dak the way
he's playing
um they're they're tough out i mean the
bucks you know won on opening night by
three
but i like that i like that football
team there's a lot of good ones in the
nfc and and really it's i think it's
going to be a premium on who wins the
division if you can win your division
and get a home game or two you'll be
okay but let's be honest
we look at the records schedules i think
everything's going through green bay and
that's you know
if the bucks or anybody else has to go
up there it's likely not going to be a
balmy day like it was a year ago and
there'll be more than 9 000 fans with
with placards banging on the stand so
that's always a tough place to play and
there's just not many teams i think the
packers are going to lose to
safe travels rick always great to talk
to you thank you
thanks dan appreciate it
that's rick stroud tampa bay times
always good to talk to him appreciate
him joining us from the airport there